you know it's increasingly apparent that
mathematics do not apply to the literary
world example mathematics tell us a
negative and a negative equal a positive
literary world if you have a shitty
author take inspiration from another
shitty author doesn't make a positive
movie doesn't make a good movie just
make [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
inspired by [ __ ] which creates more [ __ ]
it's all negative no math no logic why
are we here
50 shades of socially acceptable porn
that your girlfriend's gonna insist
she's allowed to watch even after she
made you delete your entire digital
stash I know it's completely unfair so
50 shades of grey is the movie
adaptation based on the book which is
based off a Twilight fan fiction
seriously look it up that's how that
[ __ ] started it's completely apparent
this was inspired by Twilight everyone
in this movie is an exaggeration or
cartoon version of a twilight character
you have saved me from my boring-ass
life Bella in Twilight Edward was this
really controlling shitty boyfriend this
gray guy's of course I mean he's a
dominatrix so he's more controlling I
mean this guy's a complete freak not
only I mean the S&M stuff people have
their bedroom kinks it's I get it it's
not bad it's not necessarily freaky it's
not scary but this one he's like bumped
into her a couple times at this point
she just gets his phone number and she
drunk dials them and she's like he's
like what are you drinking stop true key
right now you put down that devil water
you don't know this girl that well why
are you ordering her to do stuff just to
be a dick right there there should have
been a red flag she should have been
like no not that guy
odds are that went through her mind she
was like oh wait but he's a billionaire
all right yeah I guess I'll put up with
it yep Team Jacob friendzone is really
pathetic too he's like hey friends what
do you want to do today yeah I totally
want to [ __ ] your tits but I'm not gonna
be able to because I'm not a billionaire
this movie is the gimmick is the S&M
[ __ ] that's what sells us movie it's
ultimately it is porn
the bummer for the movies that it's
theatrically released porn so hey it
wants to play with the big boys and
wants to be judged as a movie we're
gonna judge this [ __ ] as a movie and if
jenna haze darkside was released as a
movie I feel like it's a shitty movie it
has no plot why are we here jenna haze
darkside knows what it is it knows it's
porn it knows you're gonna skip to the
good scenes it just goes on this merry
way
no one judges it for that but hey Fifty
Shades wants to be a movie all right the
leads in this movie have no chemistry
whatsoever it's the most forceful
romance since Anakin and Padme it's
terrible everyone is the idealistic
perfect version of what they need to be
for this plot to be like ooh it's like
Twilight this billionaire who's like
he's a complete playboy he does state a
masochistic [ __ ] mean you know that's
his world he's obviously completely
incompatible with this completely
innocent girl you could be like oh no he
finds that appealing but it's not that
she's innocent she's kind of open to it
she's innocent and she's boring in the
sexual aspect of it she's not
open to the possibilities as he would
want someone like her to be so you're
like why are you going after her what
are you gonna dry spell dude are you
this really attractive model looking
billionaire that doesn't have today just
thrown at him day-in day-out you just
have to go after the girl who dresses
like she sits in the front row pew of
her Bible Belt Church I don't get any of
it then there's her she's like too much
for me and a void they're going over the
contract she's like no I'm not doing
that I'm not doing that I'm not doing
that and he gets a disappointed look in
his face you think he'd be like you know
we're not that compatible I guess let's
just move on no we're separate ways and
it's not like they've known each other
for two whole days at the point where
they're like oh I'm completely
infatuated with you is that they've
bumped into each other a couple times
that's enough for them to be like oh you
know what
I need you there's even this shitty ass
line worried I mean she's like I'm a
virgin yeah she's a virgin Jesus girl
who so cherishes her virginity and has
all of her life she's never had sex but
now she's gonna give it up to this dude
that she's run into a couple times in
the course of a couple days I assess one
thing from that she's a gold-digging
[ __ ] but in the scene where she breaks
that tomb she's like I've never had sex
I'm a virgin he's like where have you
been all my life
I wasn't his hands cupping her face
she's like looking for you I was like
the amount of people that line had to
get passed to make it on-screen no one
called it no one was like you know this
shit's a stretch already but that's not
making it that's actually too bad the
fact that the lead actors have zero
chemistry in this movie that is just
terrible it's bad enough what do you
think alright what's the overall plot
the overall plot is their shitty ass
stupid romance it shouldn't be happening
because they're completely incompatible
with each other in other shitty-ass
movies where you have bad acting and it
uses sex as the driving force for the
plot there is usually bigger [ __ ]
happening Basic Instinct it's like oh
who killed the guy with the ice pick
Twilight mark this day I'm gonna use
Twilight in comparison to Fifty Shades
of Grey as the positive oh my god how
did we get here as a society at least
Twilight had the element of all the
werewolves might fight the vampires
might be a big fight going on there
might be a battle you can't have your
weird freak your hybrid baby because the
Illuminati alike tear your lives apart
and kill you in all that [ __ ] just says
there's nothing except the fact these
two kind of want to date each other but
they shouldn't and they start to realize
they shouldn't and it's just boring
that's movie there's no bigger
[ __ ] in that it's the S&M stuff that is
the gimmick that's driving the movie if
the SMM shit's not happening you're just
drudging through the bad dialogues zero
chemistry in the shitty script to get
there and even when it does happen it's
actually not that interesting and the
fact is I know a lot of my subscribers
were looking forward to me [ __ ] on
Fifty Shades of Grey and I knew that and
I was like I don't want a [ __ ] on Fifty
Shades of Grey just because you know
people are expecting me to if it's not a
shitty movie I'm gonna be like hey guess
what it's not actually as terrible as I
thought it was gonna be it's not
actually as terrible as I thought it was
gonna be it's actually worse Fifty
Shades of Grey is worse than Twilight
it's worse than [ __ ]
oh yeah it's nothing and there it is
that's the vortex friends that's the
nothing that's what the neverending
story was warning us about that is where
your pride goes when you're sitting in
this auditorium because you watch this
movie and you skipped out on Kingsman
and there's gonna be three more of these
movies I say three because there's two
more books after this one but you know
they're gonna split that last movie into
two parts it's three all right
so did your girlfriend drag you to Fifty
Shades of Grey have you seen this movie
what do you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know or if
not you can tell me if the shittiest
movie you've ever seen I really yeah
this is a good one what's the shittiest
movie you've ever seen and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more